devo più chiare qualcuno a rubargli dei
soldi dammi dei saldi
[Musica]
avete presente gta 5
ecco quello in confronto a sto gioco è
una merda tutti ragazzi è venuto il suo
video sono vari generi ed oggi samsung
christmas shopper simulator che è un
videogioco di natale è un videogioco di
natale oppure un videogioco de rossi c'è
gran battuta di merda ragazzi qualcuno
mi regali dell'umorismo per natale ne
avrei bisogno grazie comunque sia i
ragazzi l'anno scorso ho fatto christmas
show prossimo letto il primo perché non
hanno fatti due a ci sono anche puoi
scegliere i personaggi va come ci siamo
ecco
ma cosa cazzo fai l'uomo biscotto cioè
come che si chiamava il gelato così
cuccioloni tipo spero che lo paghino
abbastanza perché non mi sembra troppo
felice comunque ragazzi partiamo perché
mi sta prendendo abbastanza bene la cosa
al 27 di novembre 2015 black friday
ma tom cela che cosa fanno quelli via
via veloci e partito ragazzi due friday
open for business
togliti [ __ ] oddio [ __ ]
[ __ ] via ea dove sono quei fottuti
televisori di melo parla donna parlatori
da stronza nessuno che mi aiuti
non c'è gente che vola a caso la l'xbox
quella l'xbox versione rossa bellissima
dove cazzo vai è presto ma noi una
playstation 4.5 di quei ragazzi è
veramente così in america sopra comprato
gli assorbenti non funzionano così ti
insegno io da milano dov'è mio braccio
del cosa fai con le braccia casa sexy
che se c'è una che cosa stanno facendo
ma cosa state facendo challenge complete
ed graham greene crismas jumper di
windows e ti sotto effetto di droghe
cosa che devo prendere cosa corredava
green a questo grazie porta dalla cassa
e paga 30 dollari per questo subito dove
la cassa ecco sgancia donna sgancia
perfetto sono iniziati gli scontri dov'è
che corrono dove corrono ma doveva
ragazzi dobbiamo seguire la massa di
gente che hanno scoperto che ci sono gli
sconti quindi devo essere più veloce di
loro ma ci sono gli sconti sulla tv e
corri datemi il televisore a due euro
tamil televisione dammi il televisore
mio è mio è mio lo pago io lo pago pago
[ __ ] datemi voglio questo ecco
no ma quel televisore a 800mila pollici
costa 100 dollari non ho scelto dall
come non 100 dollari devo più chiare
qualcuno e rubargli dei soldi danni dei
soldi
[Musica]
questa è morta c'è una morta qui mica
potrei fare il medico fuori campo
ragazzi mica che porta gli ho dato fuori
nomi scusi lei non si tolga che devo
salvare questo come ho fatto a
incastrarti quei dammi la mano dammi la
mano che ti tiro super caduta oddio è
sparito domanda dov'è ma posso farmi
serpi e guarda sorridi zio orco cosa
fate foto bombardo le cose che cazzo
fanno è perchè volete tutti fare il
fotoblog bravi ragazzi perché i casi
così chi è questa c'è mica un gioco no
il vostro di seppi che è davvero presso
il bastione dei sell fini va bene lo so
io vorrei comprare ecco grazie se non mi
avesse ucciso il poliziotto per prendo
solo lui space monkey c'è un negozio
chiamato space monkey perché se vuoi la
space marche quindi non c'è la gravità
da space monkey interessante
implementare questa feature in un
negozio di oggettistica
mi scusi lei è come fa ad implementare
la gravità me lo vende per cortesia no
questo palazzo
io regalo li ho regalati io ho legato un
pallone al culo con la fila per babbo
natale toglieteli che voglio parlarci o
babbo natale scusi mi scusi ero in fila
da stamattina grazie a per caso chiesto
delle dosi di eroina
no perché vedo che funziona signor babbo
natale io sono stato un bravo ragazzo e
come regalo vorrei potermi sedere dentro
le sedie come fa lei gnocchi on heaven's
door cosa vuol dire non è italiano
quindi la pasta la conosco meglio di voi
basta la vista
vabbè geniale geniale ora che mangiare
tanta pasta non fa bene guarda sto tizio
ecco se vuoi scassato la vetrina
estintore challenges completa trova un
estintore ma cosa farà a spass par de va
bene fatevi provare con la formica
fratel e poi io ho sempre visto formiche
fare shopping per carità di dio ai
proiettori in prima persona proprio vado
veramente la velocità di una formica
però non pensavo che vuoi veramente
posso farmi serpico la formica no che
sarebbe stato se è la madonna uthman
nintendo ha certo fatemi comprare st
prestesa a nintendo
mortacci sua togliti fammi comprarmela
della fai comprare l'ho portata qua non
l'ho portato per fatta vedere dei video
comprarla trento come faccio essere poi
che cazzo succede
va bene e sto continuando a ascoltati
fermi un attimo per cortesia è
indemoniato ragazzi cosa è successo a
ecco col palo nelle palle si è fermato
cosa hai fatto
cosa c'è a ma stai facendo esercizi
pensavo stesse piangendo
oddio ma così rimorchi le donne zio
fammi capire che il cinema ragazzi c'è
anche è bella [ __ ] quella ancora che fa
esercizi ma basta siamo al cinema almeno
goditi film cazzo fa oddio l'esorcista
cazzo è sparita oddio ma ti muovi a
scatti
mi piace veramente l'esorcista fatti
fare una foto che la documentiamo
perfetto ragazzi la foto più horror del
secolo questa nomi spunta davanti mi fa
un jump schermo ma procede clipping
allora non so se mi parla poco critico
ragazzi la gente fin troppo entusiasta
però non cercare di non sei capace non
sei capace
sono morto mentre faccio un self i
ragazzi non ho mai fatto un set così
così bello da morto ciao saluto a saluta
saluta che prendo ma lei che mi dà una
mano mi calpesta mi calpesta mentre
tenta di fare sempre e questa la morta
col braccio così allora ragazzi è stato
è stato carino istruttivo e soprattutto
ci insegna come si parcheggiano le
macchine cosa molto importante è il
muletto
ci mancava il muletto certo su
sicuramente sono finito nel ok sono
andato a trovare gesuiti ragazzi che
provi episodio è stato ogni natale gioca
christmas shopper e ogni natale mi
ricordo in quanto la mia vita sia triste
anche se i ragazzi spero che avviso vi
sia piaciuto e cosa in seguito mi sono
solo come è un mi piace anche a voce di
facebook e corneille video atene
descrizione lo so che tutti vorrebbero
fare shopping calciando le persone
quando sono in fila ma è compreso se non
avessi di schettini ci vediamo al
prossimo vito dell'area
io